gotta go fast yes those are the words of
Satan and Sonic that he said I found
this website it has a bunch of Sonic
games it just looks too good not to try
out that Lee used all of them alright
here we go
sonic skate glider alright level one yes
this is justice how I remember I got an
achievement for that man no no let's
play again why does sonic need a [ __ ]
skateboard when he can jet out god
damnit Sonic what is that sound what is
that what is this game what that sonic
[Music]
what is that sound
now remember saw anything like that it's
really hard what game of the arrow yeah
is the best game ever
alright so good he just doesn't care
it's like the humiliation how much will
they [ __ ] me a loop loop come on what
was why would that [ __ ] whoever made
this game was proud of himself mom my
dream is true I finally made a game oh
that's lovely honey it's about Sonic
skating she's like get out how far is
level one I want to beat level one
alright thank you
well that was Sonic's skate Grider I'll
probably write it
six million tens out of nine next up we
have
yes I'm excited about this one race your
Bradley moving sonic step on it
whoa that speed though gotta go fast it
looks like Sonic really needs to find
the toilet this is me practically and
when I need to find a toilet this game
is a lot of fun I love video games well
that was amazing
I'll rate that one six out of six Sonic
the Hedgehog
character designer advanced edition good
good I want the advanced edition like
those feet are [ __ ] terrifying is
that of what he's feel really looks like
so we can make our own sanic here sanic
this picture that in real life
oh no I I didn't eat at him are you
[ __ ] kidding me
ah oh that's a nice [ __ ] sausage
movie by as a movie now I don't ten out
of ten best game I played here we go
sunny blocks this game has nothing
nothing to do with Sonic who who makes
these Jesus Christ sonic Surf defeat
Eggman and get him to return the Emerald
alright oh there's a giant [ __ ] play
button oh my god the framerate it's this
is what PC gamers whine we want at 60fps
up yo at I can't wait to defeat Eggman
man look at them graphics this is like
the next-gen [ __ ] ps4 a [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ] how do I jump PC master-race
will this nightmare ever end it's like
hey let's take a character that runs
fast and put him on water cuz that's dis
[ __ ] genie alright this is Sonic
Xtreme truck start yes yes yes
yeah I got can I know my god like I said
it's [ __ ] face he's so determined to
go whatever the [ __ ] he's going back
flap shut up
back flap spike sonic it's not sonic
bike it's a bike sonic level select hmm
well there's so many intricate levels
that I can choose between I don't know
which one I go with that way [ __ ] is
collecting coins I'm all about them
stars backflip I [ __ ] exploded
oh yes that that looked okay yes did it
thank you [ __ ] [ __ ] they see me bro
Sonic they hatin patrolling and trying
to get me riding sonic trying to catch
me run Sonny hates me
suck my ass senpai well [ __ ] you then
finally we're gonna play Sonic RPG I
know how to handle this run really
really you're telling me Sonic it can't
run but it can use [ __ ] magic super
for him what is that oh yeah oh yeah oh
yeah I know that one know what Eggman
what you gonna do
shut up for that's about the line what
you gonna do shoot dildos at me is he
dead yet
thank you know I level up Oh Oh skip
best game ever ever made all right we
have finally this game I'm terrified
because what is that we're playing Mario
Sonic doll
[ __ ] you Sonic you [ __ ] now this is the
game I can appreciate Sonic died and
went to heaven
is this what kids play this games is
that what you're into three Sonic's now
I've seen it all [ __ ] I shot his face
out how he's not dead thank you alright
I'm gonna have to end that episode there
like being you're watching brothers as
always I appreciate it and thank your
running it out with me today stay
awesome bro
[Music]